I can pretty easily say that the one
tool that's had the biggest impact on my
productivity as a web developer is
typescript and that's pretty amazing
considering a few years ago I had no
interest in learning it and was only
exposed to it because I had a client
that required an angular app in today's
video I'm gonna show you all the basic
concepts needed to be successful with
typescript and I'll throw in a few pro
tips here and there that I find
especially useful if you're new here
like and subscribe and there will be a
t-shirt giveaway with this video all you
have to do is leave a comment below and
we'll pick a random winner next week I
want to start with a shout-out to
basarat Syed who is the author of the
typescript deep dive book it's my go-to
resource for advanced concepts and it's
free and open source so originally I was
resistant to even learn typescript
because I wasn't super comfortable with
strong typed languages and I really
tried to avoid writing any more code
than I have to but this is the situation
where writing a little more code upfront
will pay big dividends as your project
grows the biggest benefit is actually
just tooling what you get in your IDE
like vs code when you use type
annotations or work with libraries that
are strong typed your code will be
automatically documented in the IDE so
you really have to refer back to online
documentation for the libraries that you
use in addition that compiler can catch
bugs in advance which is a far more
efficient way to refactor code
I think this reddit post says it best
would you rather have silly errors
during development or insanity inducing
errors in production another cool
benefit of typescript is that there's
virtually no learning curve if you know
JavaScript that's because it's a
superset of JavaScript so any valid jsk
is also valid in typescript so you can
learn it incrementally as you go and it
also allows us to write our code with
future JavaScript features without
having to worry about whether or not
this code will be supported in our
environment because we can transpile it
to multiple JavaScript flavors
now that you know typescript is awesome
let's go ahead and get started the first
thing you want to do is install
typescript globally with NPM doing this
will give you access to the TSC command
which will run the typescript compiler
at the time of this video I'm running
version 3.1 so the first thing we'll do
is create an indexed ES file and
typescript code on its own can't run
anywhere it won't work in the browser or
an ojs or anything like that what we do
is use the typescript compiler to
convert that typescript code to vanilla
JavaScript
let's start by writing some plain
JavaScript in our typescript file and
then compile it so we'll just say
console.log hello world then we'll go
down here to the command line and run TS
c index TS you'll notice that creates an
index j s file that's our actual
JavaScript code that we can run in the
browser or node and because we just
wrote plain JavaScript that code is
identical to what's in the index TS file
by default
typescript will compile to es 3 which
doesn't have support for async await so
let's see what happens when we write an
async function in our TS C file and then
compile it so you'll notice here that
our code gets transpiled to this
crazy-looking javascript just so we can
use async await in our main typescript
code the compiler is actually very
sophisticated and there's a ton of
different options that you can pass to
it to customize its behavior you could
pass these options and from the command
line but the standard way to do it is to
create a TS config JSON which will
automatically get picked up when you run
TS c the TS config can seem pretty
overwhelming at first but there is
usually only a few options that you have
to think about for the most part the
first one is the target and this is the
flavor of javascript that your code will
be compiled to so if we set our target
to es next and then run TS c you'll see
that it compiles our code with
async/await natively because it's
targeting the latest version of
javascript which supports that syntax
another option that we'll want to set
right away is watch true which will just
recompile our code every time we save
the file that'll just save us from
rerunning that TS c command after every
change the next option will look at is
Lib which allows us to automatically
include typings for certain environments
such as the Dom or ES 2017 so if you're
building a web application you'd want to
include that Dom library which allows
typescript to compile your code with all
the native Dom classes without any
compilation errors for example if we go
back to our code we can use the URL
class which is part of the Dom and we'll
get autocomplete and intellisense on
this class so this is where the
incredible tone of typescript starts to
come in if we hover over the class we
have integrated documentation as well as
an error message telling us exactly why
this code won't run and if we want a
really explicit view of the interface we
can right click and go to the Taipings
then we'll have a view of every property
and method that exists on this class but
usually that's not necessary because
the stuff will just autocomplete for you
as you start typing the next thing we'll
look at is the use of third-party
libraries so let's go ahead and install
lodash with NPM and you'll see that
creates a node modules folder with the
source code for lodash a lot of
mainstream libraries like firebase for
example ship with type declarations
automatically but load a shiaa is not
one of them so if we go into our index
TS and import lodash we'll get a warning
from typescript saying that there are no
declarations found which means we're not
going to get any auto complete or
intellisense in the IDE but the good
news is there's a giant mono repo out
there with community maintain types if
we go ahead and install the types in our
development environment will have
autocomplete and intellisense for every
lodash function so now that we know how
the typescript compiler works let's go
ahead and write some code that uses type
annotations there are two ways you can
strong type your code implicitly or
explicitly so let's say we have a
variable that should be a number if we
assign a value to this variable when
it's declared its type will
automatically be inferred as you can see
here it's a primitive number type then
if we go down here and try to assign a
string value to this variable it's going
to give us an error because a string is
not assignable to a number if this code
were vanilla JavaScript we wouldn't
catch this bug until we actually run our
code somewhere but with typescript we
know about it right away
unlike languages like C sharp or Java we
can actually opt out of the type system
by annotating our variable with any this
just means that this variable can be
assigned any value and the compiler
won't type check it ideally you want to
avoid doing things like this when
possible but it does give typescript a
ton of flexibility in the last example
we gave our variable an implicit number
type but what if we don't have a value
to assigned to it upfront if we don't
add any type annotations to it it's
going to be inferred as an any type so
we can assign both a string and a number
to it if we want to annotate it with a
type we can just do colon followed by
number which is one of the built-in
primitive types in JavaScript when we do
that we get an error under the string
value because we can't assign it as that
type one tip that I'll give you here is
that if you have an implicit type don't
bother
explicitly strong type in it for example
here we're assigning a value that's a
number so adding the number annotation
is really just redundant so we've looked
at some of the built-in types in
JavaScript but you
and also create your own types from
scratch first you'll give the type a
name which is typically in Pascal case
and for right now we'll just go ahead
and arbitrarily assign our style type to
a string then we can declare a variable
that's annotated with this style type
and then we'll get feedback for this
custom type instead of just a regular
string right now this is super redundant
but let's say our style type can only be
bold or italic we can create a union
type by separating them with a pipe and
now we can only assign this variable to
these two specific values and we're not
limited to just strings we could even
extend this custom type with a number so
that's pretty cool but more often than
not you'll be strong typing objects that
have multiple properties with multiple
different types let's imagine we have
two objects and we want to enforce that
this object shape has a first and last
name with string types composing objects
or class instances that don't have the
correct shape is an easy way to create
bugs in your program but with typescript
we can enforce the shape of an object
with an interface if we know that the
shape of the person object walls be the
same then we can define an interface
that defines the types on each property
now we can use this interface to strong
type these objects directly or we could
use it as the return value from a
function or as an argument or anywhere
else in our code now sometimes an
interface like this can be a little too
restrictive but you can actually
maintain the required properties and
then add any additional properties to be
added by creating a key with a type of
string with a value type of any so now a
first and last name will be required but
you can also add any additional property
that you want to this object now let's
go ahead and switch gears to functions
strong typing a function can be a little
more complex because you have types for
the arguments and also the return value
so here we just have a plain JavaScript
function without any types that raises X
to the power of Y so currently we could
add string values as the arguments here
and we wouldn't get any air from the
compiler but obviously this function is
going to fail if we try to pass it any
non-number value you can annotate
arguments the same way we do with
variables by just adding a colon and
then the type after it and that will
ensure that only numbers can be passed
to this function so the function
implicitly has a number return value
because we're using the native math
javascript library but we can annotate a
specific return value ty
after the parentheses and before the
brackets so if we set that type to a
string you'll see it's underlined in red
because it's returning a number to
implement this function correctly we can
call to string which will then clear out
that underlined error and in many cases
you might have functions that don't
return a value or create some kind of
side effect in that case you can type
your function return value to void so
you'll commonly see the void type on
functions like event listeners or
side-effects that just don't return a
value the next thing we'll look at is
how to strong type an array so we'll
start by creating an empty array and
then pushing a few different values to
it with different types we can force
this array to only have number types by
doing a number type followed by bracket
signifying that it's an array now you
can see we get an error every time we
try to push a value that's not a number
this is especially useful when you're
working with an array of objects and you
want to get some intellisense as you're
iterating over those objects for example
if we retrieved an array of people from
our database we could use our person
interface to know the exact shape of
those objects as they're retrieved
typescript also opens the door to a new
data structure called a tuple these are
found in other programming languages
like Python and basically they're just a
fixed length array where each item in
that array has its own type so we can
name our type my list and then we'll
give each of its values a different type
currently this is giving us an error
because we're initializing this array as
an empty array but the compiler is
expecting all these values to be defined
up front so one thing you can do is make
these values optional by putting a
question mark after the type and you can
also use this question mark syntax and
other places in typescript for example
to make function arguments optional the
last thing I want to show you is
typescript generics you may run into
situations where you want to use a type
internally inside of a class or function
a good example is an rxjs observable
which itself is just a class that has an
internal value that you can observe so
the capital T in this code represents a
variable type that we can pass in to
strong type this observables internal
value so this allows us to specify the
internal type at some later point in our
code for example we might have an
observable of a number or maybe we have
an observable of our person interface
and we can also do this implicitly if we
create a new observable of a number it's
going to implicit
we have that internal number type so
more often than not you'll be using
generics rather than creating them but
it's definitely an important thing to
know I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there hopefully this video gave you
an idea of why typescript is so powerful
but we really only scratched the surface
here I'd like to do a video on object
oriented versus functional programming
and typescript or possibly decorators so
let me know what you want to see next in
the comments if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to learn more consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase comm
you'll get unlimited access to my
following courses as well as project
support on slack and of course I will
mail you this laptop sticker that you
see on the screen now thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon